I wouldn't know because I blacked out
for the entire period yeah it was just
Blake was just behind me awkwardly
manipulating my body
it was amazing her son is a deadpool fan
I brought him the Deadpool mask look at
that I mean that's kind of amazing it is
kind of, like are you at her concert
where is this. I'm trying to figure out
where I thought this was, on a cruise ship
yeah is it a cruise ship? spoiler alert we're
having dinner at our apartment
are their plans for yet another
Deadpool in the Franchise? oh yeah yeah
we're working on it right now with the
whole team we're over at Marvel now yeah!
which is like, the big leagues all of a
sudden. it's kind of crazy so yeah we're
working on it. and you're also working on with the rock
on a new film like that
I know right
welcome back everyone its
Charlie we have big Deadpool 3 Marvel
news so Ryan Reynolds is doing the talk
show circuit explaining what's going on
with Deadpool 3 we know a little bit
about what's going on behind the scenes
so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
going to be a whole bunch of big Marvel
stuff happening real soon
we're doing a new Marvel Amazon giveaway
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions about Deadpool 3 on the
video so if you're wondering why Ryan
Reynolds is wearing an ugly sweater
going on the morning talk show circuit
he's just promoting that Netflix movie
that he made with Michael Bay I'm not
going to be talking about that that's not
really relevant to what's going on with
Deadpool 3 it's just that while he's
going around doing this everyone's
asking him what's going on with him at
Marvel are you going to  make Deadpool 3 of
course he's going to make it he's been
talking about it for a while now the
reason why he's doing this wearing the
ugly sweater from last year is because
it's a big callback to the prank war
that he's been having with Hugh Jackman
that goes back to the first Deadpool
movie it's funny how no matter what he
does it all goes back to Deadpool
somehow but the really important stuff
in all this is that he's just explaining
how they've been actively working on
Deadpool 3 inside Marvel so when he says they're working on it right now he's
talking about his inner circle
production team which right now is
mostly just the writers from the first
Deadpool movies Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick they've also been talking about
what's going on with Deadpool at Marvel
now in Deadpool 3 all good stuff though
the only people that have been kicked
off the Deadpool team since Marvel got
control those characters again are some
of the upper-level Fox producers that
have moved on to other projects because
Kevin Feige is now producing Deadpool 3
himself and when I mean they're making
it inside Marvel obviously
metaphorically they're making it under
the Marvel umbrella because Marvel
controls all the Fox x-men Fantastic
Four characters now but it also means
literally inside the Marvel offices down
the hallway from Kevin Feige you
probably remember the stories that the
Russos and the writers from Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame told
about how they had a giant conference
room that was literally down the hallway
from Kevin Feige just plastered wall-to-wall with all
kinds of crazy charts and plans to keep
track of those two movies when they were
busy writing the actual movies the
why a lot of the Marvel movies get
written that way is so the Kevin Feige
can actually physically walk down the
hallway and poke his head into all the
different movies writers rooms as
they're being written and give them
notes you also may remember earlier this
year Ryan Reynolds dropped a funny
Deadpool three Marvel phase 5 teaser for
the anniversary of the date that he
leaked the original Deadpool test
footage from the first film at the time
it was kind of hard to tell if he was
just having fun on his own or if he was
actually trying to imply that he'd
already worked out a deal with Kevin
Feige on how they'd work on Deadpool 3
everything is just a little bit
different now that they're under
Marvel's supervision but all the things
that Kevin Feige in the big executives
Marvel and Disney have said have been
good things they don't want to change
Deadpool or anything like that within
the Deadpool movies and they also want
to find a way to use him inside the
traditional MCU movies like the big
Avengers films eventually there's a
little bit of nuance to that because
you're not going to be seeing him dropping f-bombs all over a pg-13 Avengers movie
but they did say that they would allow
them to make r-rated Deadpool films
while they're with Marvel I did a whole
easter egg video about this here but
it's basically Ryan Reynolds acting like
Deadpool himself was trying to solve the
mystery as to who leaked the Deadpool
test footage all the names of the people
on the board here are people that were
involved in the making and development
of the original Deadpool movie including
some of the Fox executives but if you
guys didn't know it was actually Ryan
Reynolds himself that leaked that test
footage we have no idea how that
happened but I promise you I'm looking
into it because initially Fox wasn't
going to make the movie the test footage
was created back in 2011 but it was
around the time Green Lantern came out
and after that movie bombed right after
the 2009 Wolverine Origins debacle
happened Fox was just a hard pass on any kind of r-rated Deadpool film but Ryan
Reynolds and Tim Miller thought that
they could do the character justice so a
couple years later at Comic Con in 2014
after the project had kind of stalled
out and the test footage had been
sitting on a shelf on a hard drive for a
couple years
Ryan Reynolds leaked the footage on
purpose you all probably remember it
blew up huge everyone loved it and it
sort of controlled the conversation at
Comic Con that year that was the big
thing and within a few days Fox greenlit
the original Deadpool movie and they
were off to the races so
this just commemorates that anniversary
while also teasing the new Marvel
version of Deadpool 3 like he says in
the little caption here 5 year plan 5
phase plan as in Marvel phase 5 right
now the best scenario for when they
would actually release Deadpool 3 is
probably 2022 like if you look at all
these dates here for the untitled movies
that would be after Black Panther 2
which we know is coming out May 20-22
which actually seems like that might
wind up being the first true Marvel
movie with x-men Fantastic Four
characters deeply integrated into the
plot because the rumor is as the Doctor
Doom is going to be the main villain a
black panther - there is an untitled
Marvel movie scheduled for October 2022
that would probably be where they
release Deadpool 3 and as for the story
of Deadpool 3 the characters and how it
fits into the MCU movies the biggest
thing is the Kevin Feige the Disney CEO
in the Deadpool 3 writers have all said
that they're still going to let them do it
as an r-rated Deadpool movie but the way
it's probably going to work because they
do want Deadpool inside MCU movies
eventually - crossing over with the
other mainstream Avengers characters is
that when he appears in the mainstream
Marvel films like an Avengers film he'd
have to be a pg-13 version of himself
but he can be as crazy and hardcore as
he wants in the r-rated Deadpool solo
films same goes for when other Marvel
characters show up inside the Deadpool
r-rated solo films like they're not
going to let Chris Evans be Captain America or Robert Downey jr. show up as Iron Man
in an r-rated Deadpool film being super
hardcore like the Hulk isn't going to show
up and start ripping Deadpool and half
all the sudden but the Deadpool people
now have access to all the Marvel
characters so remember in the first
Deadpool film how they traded a lot on
x-men humor he went to the x-mansion and
complained because the movie was so
low-budget they couldn't afford big
mainstream x-men characters they made
all the jokes about how the big a-list
x-men characters didn't want to have
anything to do with him which is why you
had the lesser characters like colossus
and negasonic teenage warhead coming to
deal with him now that he's inside the
MCU you just have to picture him going
up against say like a C or B list Marvel
villain and then complaining about how
the Avengers don't want to help him out
because they're either all dead or
retired like in the case of Hawkeye like
he made all the Wolverine jokes at the
beginning of Deadpool -
about him dying in Logan imagine him
doing the same thing with Iron Man
Robert Downey jr. wouldn't come on
screen himself but he could trade on a
lot of Iron Man jokes he could also
trade on a lot of spider-man Tom Holland
jokes but they couldn't have Tom Holland
come on screen that would involve like a
completely separate deal with Sony -
which is why you probably won't see
spider-man inside a Deadpool movie
anytime soon
and even though Black Panther 2 seems
like it might be the first genuine big
Fantastic Four crossover you have to
remember that there was a version of
Deadpool - the Tim Miller was working on
before he left the project which was
going to have the thing in a bunch of
Yancy Street stuff going on during it
instead of the juggernaut stuff I don't
know that that would have been better
but it would have been fun to see some
Fantastic Four stuff given how badly the
last Fantastic Four movie went seriously
I'm so excited for Kevin Feige smart
version of Fantastic Four we've in rock
bottom with that franchise so many times
that there's nowhere to go with those
characters but up so everyone let me
know in the comments thinking about all
that stuff what do you want them to do
with the Deadpool solo films that are
still going to be r-rated which B and C
lists Marvel villains do you want them
to include in that now it would be fun
to see some mainstream Avengers but I'm
only expecting them to be making jokes
about some of the dead Avengers
characters remember the montage that
they did at the beginning of spider-man
far from home just a really funny jokey
way of referencing all the big stuff
that happened during Avengers endgame it would be funny to see them reference
something like that inside Deadpool 3
even if it's only just a couple seconds
and a quick joke you may have also seen
Kevin Feige did a really big panel
recently for Marvel phase 4 talked a lot
about Doctor Strange - so I will do a
breakdown video for that stuff in the
next day or so but leave all your Marvel
video requests in the comments below and post all your Deadpool 3 predictions on
the video everyone click here for my
Mandalorian episode 8 finale video and
click here for my last really big black
widow trailer breakdown in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!